con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar del referendo para la
aprobación de un nuevo discutido código
de la familias en Cuba que se votará
este domingo 25 de septiembre y que
tendrá que contar con el sí de mayoría
simple de todos los votos válidos para
ser adoptado a esta Norma que reemplaza
a una de 1975 75 provocó una gran
polémica Y tuvo mucha resistencia en los
meses pasados sobre todo entre los
grupos conservadores y religiosos e
Iglesias que rechazan el matrimonio
igualitario la adopción por parte de
personas del mismo sexo o también los
vientres subrogados nosotros saludamos
entonces a Jesús Delgado Valery Él es
director de desarrollo institucional y
transparencia electoral coordinador de
demomat Gracias por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de viernes en directo
América de Francia 24 Jesús y le
pregunté entonces la importancia de esta
votación para los cubanos que tan
abierta es la sociedad de La Isla
Hola qué tal Buenos días Muchas gracias
por la invitación Bueno Raúl yo creo que
antes de avanzar con el código y con el
contenido que se está Play visitando
tenemos que empezar con una breve
descripción no de lo que son los
procesos electorales en Cuba son
procesos electorales totalmente
controlados por la élite del partido
comunista haciendo un repasando los
antecedentes de experiencias
plebicitarias tenemos desde la llegada
de la Revolución la del 76 y la idea del
2019 ambas para reprender constituciones
y con aprobaciones por encima del 90%.
ahora bien llegamos a a este escenario
no este nuevo código de la familia que
como tú decías incluye temas como los
dientes subrogados o quizás más polémico
el matrimonio igualitario y en este
sentido el gobierno cubano decide como
una estrategia también de Pink washing
someter a referendo un código como como
el código nuestras familias para poder
vender a la comunidad internacional y
también a grupos internos una imagen de
progresismo el gobierno cubano no tiene
ninguna meter un código como este
referendo la legislación electoral no
contempla digamos esta obligación y lo
hace simplemente para poder vender un
ejercicio de participación ciudadana y
democrático en el que se ganan más
derechos esto ha tenido una gran
repercusión dentro de la isla como tú
decía hay muchos grupos conservadores
religiosos pero también hay una gran
cantidad de personas que quizás no se
siente identificada con estos grupos y
sin embargo tiene una idea tradicional
de familia o también hay un grupo muy
importante que le parece indiferente lo
que regula este código Pero quiere
aprovechar esta ocasión para demostrar
su descontento con el gobierno votando
por el rechazo Jesús incluso algunos
miembros de la comunidad lgbti de La
Isla criticaron que haya que votar por
algo que son los Derechos Humanos Más
allá de la orientación sexual y de
género digamos que como también puede
ser la participación en este sentido de
esta comunidad
si es que refrendar derecho es un
despropósito no someter a una mayoría
circunstancial los derechos de las
minorías va en contra de toda la
experiencia
sobre Derechos Humanos a nivel regional
y a nivel mundial es lo que se está
haciendo en Cuba con un propósito
político recordemos que el gobierno
cubano sobre todo para garantizar
cooperación por ejemplo en el Unión
Europea lo que hace es asumir compromiso
o de liberalización o democratización a
futuro y en este sentido este código le
da una herramienta para poder venderlo
al exterior como una como un progreso
Digamos como un avance en materia de
derechos el mismo gobierno cubano desde
el mismo presidente Miguel Díaz canel el
canciller e incluso la titular del
Consejo electoral nacional están
haciendo campaña a favor del Sí todo el
aparato del Estado está siendo
propaganda a favor del sí aunque la ley
electoral en su Artículo 85 prohíbe o
excluye la
electoral o la propaganda electoral el
gobierno Está tomando eso como una
Digamos como una lucha propia ha tenido
obviamente la confluencia de
agrupaciones
luchando desde hace muchos años por sus
derechos y en este caso por el
matrimonio igualitario pero no hay que
dejar de lado que se trata de un
ejercicio en el que se están placitando
derechos y en el que se están dejando en
manos de una mayoría de los derechos de
las minorías esto es un despropósito va
en contra de toda la experiencia y las
recomendaciones en materia de derechos
humanos y es lo que vamos a ver el
próximo 25 de septiembre como bien lo
decía Jesús él no ha tenido poca
presencia digamos en esta campaña
electoral incluso activistas opositores
aunque no estén de acuerdo con esto ya
llaman a la abstención para precisamente
eso no legitimar al gobierno de Miguel
Díaz canel
Así es Y recordemos que en el ejercicio
playcitario anterior en
la 19 ya hubo una gran cantidad de
atención un 15% y hubo un rechazo un 9%
esto suma un caso un 25% de personas que
o decidieron no votar o votar por él no
que en la cual Revolucionaria bueno Esto
da una demostración no en contra del
gobierno donde no hay elecciones
cualquier tipo de ejercicio prioritario
se usa justamente para demostrar el
rechazo a al gobierno Más allá de
aquello de lo que se está felicitando no
en Cuba efectivamente no hay respeto por
los Derechos Humanos no hay instancias
para amparar los derechos o recurrir
antes de distintas violaciones el caso
más emblemático y también más recientes
son las protestas el paso cada 11 de
Julio 2021 donde todavía al día de hoy
hay cientos de presos que quedaron
digamos este detenidos por el solo hecho
de manifestar desde hacer su derecho a
la manifestación entonces obviamente hay
una contradicción cuando hay
su derecho la manifestación incluso
niños menores de edad que todavía están
detenidos y al mismo tiempo se habla de
un código del amor o código de los
afectos como como le está llamando ahora
el oficialismo para obviamente hacer
estas estrategia de Ping washing y
apropiarse de una lucha o
instrumentalizar una lucha que ha sido
muy difícil para una comunidad lgbt que
recordemos la abuela de los años 60 y 70
era condenada campos de trabajo forzosos
claro además se trata este del Tercer
referendo desde el triunfo de la
Revolución en el año 59 y precisamente
eso eso eso le quería decir digamos es
algo que está haciendo el gobierno
cubano de puertas para afuera pero
puertas para adentro es diferente porque
también hemos visto y hemos pues
recibido también y hemos visto una
prensa varias denuncias de la comunidad
terebete que sufren siempre
discriminación también sufren hasta de
golpizas por parte de la sociedad cubana
Entonces como digamos como el gobierno
del presidente Miguel Díaz canel va a
poder controlar esto realmente proteger
y llevar a cabo esto que habla de
matrimonio igualitario de la adopción de
personas Al mismo sexo y luchar digamos
contra el estigma que tiene la sociedad
cubana sobre todo también esta comunidad
sí es un escenario en conciliable como
tú lo dices por un lado no hay garantías
de derechos no hay garantías de acceso a
la justicia de Amparo no la la sociedad
cubana y sobre todo la sociedad civil
cubana está desamparada no encuentra
digamos respaldo en la legislación que
ya existen la Constitución cubana que
prevé o establece el derecho a la
manifestación y son digamos muestras un
ejemplo de que esto no se cumple cuando
realizamos la cantidad de presos
políticos la cantidad de torturados la
cantidad expatriados 200.000 personas
cubanas han entrado a los Estados Unidos
en los últimos 11 meses de esa protestad
el 11 de Julio Entonces no no no se
condice no hay coherencia
que la sociedad civil cubana con un
código que habla o se titula no como
código de los afectos códigos del amor
código de los niños el código de la
esperanza la verdad que no no hay
coherencia entre lo que está sucediendo
y esta aspiración normativa no que
establece el código de